RICHARD HYNDMAN: Kaj Nygren,
the CTO of Mag Interactive,
is coming up to
share with you what
happened when one of their
games exploded across the world,
and how they dealt
with the situation.
Please welcome Kaj.
[APPLAUSE]
KAJ NYGREN: Right, so
good afternoon, everybody.
My name is Kaj
Nygren, as he said.
I'm the CTO Mag Interactive.
And what I'm going to talk
you about today is handling
extreme growth,
or how we managed
to scale our game, Ruzzle,
from zero to 50 million users
in a very short period of time.
So who are we?
Well Mag Interactive is a
mobile game development company.
We were based in
Stockholm, in Sweden.
We like to think that we sit a
few hundred meters from King,
whereas people
here like to think
that they sit just
underneath of King.
We have a bit of a debate
of where if King is
like a Swedish company,
or an English company.
But anyway, we were
founded back in 2010.
We are currently
at 27 employees,
and we're hoping to double
that in 2014, this year.
So we had two games
live, as the sale.
We have a game called
Ruzzle, a word game,
with a bit over
50 million users.
We also have a quiz game, kind
of like the little brother
of Ruzzle, which has something
like six million users
or something like that.
We also actually have a new
game in the pre-launch face,
called Ruzzle adventure,
which is a follow up Ruzzle.
So it's currently in
soft launch in Sweden.
We launched it a few days ago,
and it's doing pretty well.
It's currently number
one on the Play,
or on the app store
in Games in Sweden.
So that's pretty exciting.
But anyway, I guess
most of you here
are either interested in
games, or game developers.
If you're a game
developer, and especially
if you're a game developer
in the mobile space,
you want to hit it big on the
App Store or in Google Play.
You want to have a mobile hit.
But, I'm sorry, I
guess the sad thing
is that, the harsh reality
is, that most games fail.
And it is kind of weird, though.
Because there is, if
you think about it,
there's $2 billion smartphones
and tablets out there.
And App Store and Google
Play makes it very easy
to download stuff.
So you would think
that there would
be enough devices and enough
people for all the games,
but the thing is,
people are lazy.
So what they typically do is
that they talk with friends
to find out which
games are hot and cool
and that they should download.
And other than that, they
usually just go to the top 5,
top 10 charts and try to
download games from there.
So there is a huge
app discovery problem.
So you end up in
a situation where
the vast majority of all the
games get very little download.
And a few games get the vast
majority of all the downloads.
Now to complicate this a bit
further, if you are very, very
lucky and you happen to have
some type of social media hit,
you will get an enormous
amount of downloads
in a very short period of time.
Because that's when the
2 billion devices really
kicks in.
So this obviously is a
very, very slim chance
of it happening.
But it might happen.
And that makes it a
bit tricky if you're
doing a mobile
game that will have
some type of mobile backend.
Because it might be that it's
like a player versus player
game, or that you have some
type of downloadable content,
or it's just that
you want to send
push notifications to people.
The thing is, the
most likely scenario
is that you put
your game out there
and it will have a few
downloads, but not that many.
But then suddenly, boom!
Something can happen.
And you will get a
vast amount of download
in a very short period of time.
So how do you prepare for that?
Well that's a very
good question.
And I guess the reason why I'm
here to talk to you about this
is that what happened to
Flappy Bird, about a month ago,
kind of happened to one of
our games, about a year ago.
So as I said, we have a
word game called Ruzzle.
It's a game where you have
a set of 16 tiles, letters,
and you compete
against each other
in trying to find as many words
as possible in two minutes.
It's like a Boggle-type game,
if you've ever played Boggle.
So it's player versus
player, it has leaderboards,
in-game chatting, friend
lists, achievements.
It's also
cross-platform, so it's
available in iOS, Android,
and Windows phone.
So obviously given
this, we do have
some type of mobile
backend to handle this.
We launched this in March, 2012.
And actually almost
immediately became a viral hit
in Stockholm, or in Sweden.
It took us nine days to become
number one on the Swedish app
store.
We had all these kids
playing in the schoolyards,
and you had Swedish
celebrities tweeting about
that this was like
the new Plague.
And we appeared in cartoons
and newspapers and all that.
So that was pretty cool,
since we're a Swedish company.
Shortly afterwards we also
hit it big in the Netherlands,
and we also became number
one in Norway and Denmark
shortly after.
So we were doing pretty well.
But to be honest, I mean
these are small countries.
So we had something like 5 or
6 million downloads, I guess.
Something like that.
So we were doing pretty well.
We thought we were
doing pretty well.
But then in December,
2012 something happened.
We suddenly became a viral hit
in the United States and Italy
at the same time.
Now this is actually
pretty cool,
because we have Google
Analytics integrated in Ruzzle.
So we could track
on a daily basis
where people were playing.
So we know for a fact
that in the United States
it started in a very small
town down in Mississippi.
Where, most likely,
high school teenagers
found out about
Ruzzle and started
to play against each other.
And then after a
few days, we could
see that it had spread
from that little city
to the neighboring cities.
And then it spread to the
capital of Mississippi.
And then it's spread to
the neighboring states.
And then it just spread
like a viral disease
all across America.
And kind of the same
thing happened in Italy
at the same time.
So obviously when
these things happen,
it has an impact on the number
of downloads that you get.
So this is what our
download charts looked like.
So the thing to remember
here is that the flat line
at the bottom that
you see, looks
like almost nothing,
that's actually
a pretty healthy 30,000
downloads per day.
But that grew within
a few weeks to close
to a million downloads per day.
Usually when you see
charts like this,
that's usually when the
marketing department, they just
go two thumbs up, and go
out and drink champagne.
Whereas the guys in
the server department
they just cross their
fingers, pray to God,
and you just hope
everything sticks together.
And for one reason
or another, I tend
to end up in the
server department.
Because the thing is,
I mean inevitable,
if you have an exponential
increase in downloads,
you will have an exponential
increase in traffic.
And to just give
an idea what kind
of numbers that we were dealing
with, we added, as I said,
almost a million users per day.
We had pretty good retention
numbers, so most of those users
actually came back
the day after,
where we added yet
another million users.
We just kept on adding users,
users, users, and all of those
are hitting our servers.
We ended up in a situation
where we, on our peak,
we had about 100
million games being
played every day on our service.
We sent out 150 million
push notifications today.
And we had a sustained load
on the servers from the games,
at roughly 30,000
requests per second.
And to tell you the truth, I
mean we did have some problems.
We had to tweak the
architecture a bit.
We had to do some optimizations.
But for the most
part, everything just
scaled beautifully.
So that was pretty, pretty cool.
Now how did we do that?
What are the key
things that you think
about when you design a
game with a mobile backend?
So you have essentially
a few options
that Google has been
talking about here.
If you have a simple
game, it might not
be player versus
player, so you just
need leaderboards, for example.
Or it's something which is
it's player versus player,
but you don't have any
special consideration
in how you do matchmaking.
Then you might be well off
using the Google Play Services,
or Game Center if
you're strictly on iOS.
And then on the other
spectrum, if you
were doing real-time
gaming, maybe you're
doing a Call of
Duty style thing,
or you're doing new Clash
of Clans type things,
you actually might have to
write a lot of stuff yourself,
and put it in the cloud, and
[INAUDIBLE] server solution.
But there is a middle
ground as well,
and that's using AppEngine.
That's what we ended up doing.
I'm going to tell
you a little story.
I was the guy who ended up doing
the evaluation on how we're
supposed to solve the problem of
having a server in the middle.
So I was basically evaluating
all the various options
that we had.
So we were basically
contemplating either
writing stuff ourselves
and putting it on Amazon,
or using AppEngine.
We had this development
chart for Ruzzle,
where we had a project plan.
And a huge chunk of
this project plan
was allocated in doing
server development.
So when I started reading
about these things,
I just realized
that it was actually
pretty simple to do
this using AppEngine.
So I went back to the
guys and I said, well
I think we have overestimated
the amount of time
that it would take us to
do this using AppEngine.
And they said, no, no, no,
this is hugely complex.
This is a very, very
difficult problem.
So it's going to
take a lot of time.
I guess just to
prove them wrong--
this was on a Friday-- I just
went home and wrote about 80%
of the stuff that we needed
to do to get Ruzzle up
and launched over the weekend.
Including client-server
communication, and the client
side protocols,
and all that stuff.
So it's hyperproductive.
It's really, really
fast to do things in it.
So that's one of the key
advantages of using AppEngine.
So now we knew that we
could do this, technically.
But you also need to try to
do your homework on economics.
So you have to try to estimate
the server costs that you
will have per daily active user.
You also have to try
to estimate the revenue
that you will get per
daily active user,
because then you
know that you can
run this service on a
profit, and not on a loss.
And that the server
costs wouldn't eat up
your profit margin.
And the cool thing about
using cloud services
is that ideally the cost
will adapt with traffic.
So if you launched
a game and you
don't have that much traffic,
at least the server side part
of it won't cost you that much.
And if you suddenly
end up in a situation
where you have a lot
of traffic, if you've
done your math correctly,
you shouldn't actually
have a problem.
You should just be glad.
Also there's a lot of third
party solutions out there
that help you with things
like push notifications, crash
analysis, analytics,
things like that.
A lot of these services,
they charge you
per monthly active user.
And you should make sure when
you do that that they-- I mean,
if you have a game that has a
lot of monthly active users,
but you don't actually earn
that much from each user,
these services might become
prohibitively expense.
So you have to
keep track of that.
You also ideally should
verify all these assumptions
by launching on
the trial market.
We didn't do that
for Ruzzle because we
didn't understand
that we should.
But we do that nowadays.
That brings us to analytics.
It's like a lot of people
here have been saying,
nowadays if you
launch a game, it's
not that you launch a product
and then boom, you're done.
Gaming nowadays is much,
much more like a service.
So it's vital that
you know who's
playing the game, who's
not playing the game, who's
leaving the game, and why
are they leaving the game.
So you have to have some
type of analytic solution
that can capture all these
relevant stuff, like the D1, D7
retentions.
Daily active uses,
monthly active uses,
the revenue get per user
per day, things like that.
How many-- by the
way, do you know
what we mean by D7 retention?
Hardly anyone.
Right, so the idea
with D1 retention
is that typically if you
install the game, that's D0.
if you come back exactly the
day after to play the game,
that's D1.
So if you have 50% of
your users coming back
the day after to play the game,
you have a 50% D1 retention.
If you have 30% of your users
coming back exactly seven days
after installation,
that's a 30% D7 retention.
Now why are these
numbers important?
Well the thing is, if
you know these numbers,
you can actually calculate
the player lifetime.
That is, how many days of
activity your player will have.
And if you know that, and
you know the average number
of revenue you get
per daily active user,
you can actually
calculate how much money
you'll earn on each
specific download.
Which is pretty
important, if you
give the game away for free.
So if you don't have analytics,
you don't know this stuff.
So you actually
have to know this.
Also you need to be
able to handle cohorts,
so you can do AB testing
and all these things,
because that's really,
really super important.
So you know that you
don't make the game worse
when you do changes.
And most important,
you have to make sure
that your analytic
solution scales as well.
Because if you have
lots of traffic coming
in from a lot of new users,
you will generate tons and tons
of events, and you make sure
that that analytical solution
can handle this.
Now having said
all this, I thought
I'd give you a sneak
peak of how we actually
do things, how we
have solved things.
So this is how our
architecture looks like.
We are using Google
Cloud Services heavily.
And the core of the
whole thing is AppEngine.
So we essentially have
built a lot of service
on top of AppEngine, where
we handle things like users.
We have our own user database,
so we recognize all the users
within our system.
All the games being played,
all the chatting, leaderboards,
all of that is
done in AppEngine.
We expose an encrypted REST
API towards the client,
so that they can
communicate with AppEngine.
We use caching through
Memcache, and we also
do our own matchmaking.
We have a rather
advanced matchmaking
that makes sure that when you
try to find a random opponent
you will find somebody
with the same type
of behavioral patterns
that you have.
So you're not being
frustrated by having
to wait for the other opponent,
if you're an eager player.
And also that you meet somebody
with the right skill level.
So we have backends
that take care
of matchmaking,
things like that.
We also do, as I
said, analytics.
And we use BigQuery mainly
for all our analytics.
So the cool thing about BigQuery
is that it's constant in time,
but linear in cost.
And that means that if you do--
it's really super fast as well.
But the thing is, if
I take 10 million rows
and I do a complex
query, I might
get an answer in 13 seconds.
And then I do the same query,
but I throw in 10 billion rows,
it still takes 13 seconds.
It's just it costs you more.
And that makes it ideal if
you're doing in-game analytics,
because you will generate tons
and tons and tons of events.
And as long as you
can do the analytics,
and can accept the cost of doing
analytics, this thing is ideal.
So what we do is that
within AppEngine we
have trigger points.
So for example when
people register, or they
play games or whatever, we
generate a lot of events.
We stream these events in real
time through GCS into BigQuery,
and then we do daily
jobs, aggregation jobs,
to calculate retention figures,
daily active users, things
like that on different markets.
And then we have built
executive dashboards
on top of that, so
that the management can
go in and interactively go
in to monitor all the games
and how they perform
on various markets.
We also compliment this
with further like BI systems
that we integrate.
For example, ad revenues
into a consolidated place,
so we can have a
monitoring to make sure
that how much we are actually
earning from ads, on all
the various markets on
all of the 25 various ad
networks that we're
using globally.
So we're using Compute Engine
and Cloud SQL for that.
We also do third
party analytics.
We have other
third party systems
that we integrate
into this as well.
We also do push messaging.
So for Android
and Windows Phone,
it's more or less
straightforward.
Whenever we actually want
to send a push message,
we do it straight from
AppEngine straight
onto the various endpoints.
iOS is a bit more
complicated, so we actually
have our own push
notification gateway
that we run in the cloud.
So we use that to
communicate from AppEngine.
And then we send that
through to Apple Service
and down to the devices as well.
So to make this a little
less abstract for all of you,
I thought I'd go through a
bit of a case study of how
we actually work with these
things on a daily basis.
So a typical example would be
that our marketing department
would essentially
come back to us
and say, OK, it looks like
the monthly active users have
started to drop in France.
So we want to do some type of
targeted re-activation campaign
for those French users.
So what we typically
would do then
is that we, through
BigQuery, we try
to identify the
valuable players that we
want to get back into the game.
So we extract those users.
We then do MapReduce job
into the BigTable database
at Datastore, to extract those
actual user data that we have.
And queue those
into a task queue,
which is like Google's
asynchronous queue handling
that they have.
So that we enqueue
those so that we
can send push notifications
to these people.
We also typically try to
identify users patterns.
So if you're, for
example, typically you
play Ruzzle on the way
to work in the morning,
we would know that
between 8:00 and 8:30
in the morning, that's
usually when you play.
So if we want to retarget you
as a user, to say come back
and play, that's obviously
exactly in the time slot
that we want to send that
push notification to you.
So we try to do that.
And also finally, after
we've done all this,
we would then use
BigQuery to try
to analyze the outcome of this.
How many percent of
the users actually
did come back and play,
and how much money more can
we earn from this,
so we know that we're
doing it in the right way.
We also typically try to
do this with A/B tests,
so we try to change
messages, to try
to see which messages
are working better
than others, things like that.
So I guess that's more
or less it for me.
We are really super happy that
we went with the various cloud
services that we're using.
It's been working
fantastically for us.
So I can highly recommend it.
But needs may vary, so it
depends on what type of game
you're doing, and
all that stuff.
But for us it's been fantastic.
So that's about it.
The last thing is
that we are hiring.
So if you're a really
skilled game developer,
and you're happy to
move to Stockholm,
because it's a beautiful city,
then come to see me afterwards.
Other than that, questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
KAJ NYGREN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: What were the
differentiating factors that
made you choose Google AppEngine
over something like AWS Elastic
Beanstalk?
KAJ NYGREN: I'd put it this way.
First of all, why--
Elastic Beanstalk is
a lot more of doing--
it's like a mixture.
It's a halfway from just
doing a virtual like AVS, AWS,
it's halfway to that
and an AppEngine.
So you don't get as
much things for free.
The cool thing here is
that you have like an API
directly into BigTable.
You have a shared Memcache.
You have backends that you
can run for other tasks.
You have task queues for
asynchronous handling,
you have a lot of these things
that you just get for free.
And usually it's just
a few lines of code
to do this, to get things done.
Whereas using
Elastic Beanstalk is
much more of doing ordinary Java
development that just scales.
So I guess that's
my answer to that.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks for
sharing all of that data
and how you do things, and
congrats on your success.
Just a question that's
related to the last panel.
I don't know the game that well,
but looking at the art style,
and you mention that it's
played in kids' playgrounds
or at schools, is this
a young kids game?
Or is it preteen?
And if so, can you comment
on how you monetized?
What model you used?
And also what kind
of infrastructure
you might have to have for
things like all the player
to player chats with regards
to younger players, and safety,
and if that touches your game?
I'm not sure.
KAJ NYGREN: I'm actually
quite glad to say
that we have a very
broad audience.
We have people who are
playing Ruzzle-- obviously
they need to be able
to read, otherwise
it would be difficult,
this is a word-based game.
But we have people that play
Ruzzle that are from 12 to 85
probably, in age.
I'd say that in Sweden
Ruzzle was probably
the first mobile
game that people
were playing for
a lot of people.
We had a lot of old
people who just came in
because they loved the
playing experience.
So no, we don't target
just young players.
We just, I guess, like to have
a playful style of our artwork.
But it's actually
for a grown audience.
Other than that we try
to monitor our chats.
I mean obviously we have
incidents with chats.
Some things happen.
So if people report
things to us,
we actually sometimes we report
to authorities things that
happened.
So we try to do that actively.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I have two questions, actually.
KAJ NYGREN: Yep.
AUDIENCE: First of all, all
the CR magic behind Bing,
or going viral, so having
a game for one year
or so, and then just
from one day to another
going to one million downloads.
And then when you
went viral and you had
one million daily active users,
did you do any other marketing?
Did you use those money
to get even more users?
KAJ NYGREN: Yeah, first
of all, a clarification.
It's not that we have one
million daily active users.
We added one million
daily active users today.
So what's the magic?
That's a very good question.
If I actually knew all
the magic that we have,
then we would have probably
30 games of the same caliber.
But there is something
in the game play
that appeals to a broad
audience, that's very sticky.
Otherwise it wouldn't work.
We do add and have things
that support virality.
Like for example
in Italy, Facebook
was a huge part of the virality.
People were inviting each
other a lot on Facebook.
In the United States it was
that we had Twitter integration.
So Ruzzle was actually
the top tweeted word
for awhile in the world.
AUDIENCE: You said
that-- or that graph
was showing that you had 30,000
new users up until December,
which in my opinion, is enough
to get a game going viral.
So I just don't understand
what was the point--
KAJ NYGREN: The tipping point.
Why it actually struck.
That's a good question.
As I said, when we
launched in Sweden,
it took us nine days
to become a viral hit.
It's just that we had a
super duper cool game.
That's the short answer.
So yeah, there is some
magic to it, obviously.
And there's also obviously
some internal magic of things,
and why we think that
we actually became
hits in various countries.
And I can't share all that data.
As to do we do user
acquisition, yes we do as well.
On some markets
we hit because we
knew that we are
potentially viral.
So we do user requisition.
And then you hit
the tipping point,
and then you go viral like this.
In other markets,
like in the States,
we had planned to do user
acquisition and marketing
activities, but
we hadn't started.
So that was spontaneous.
These things can happen.
Like Flappy Bird
for example, that's
just spontaneous as well.
AUDIENCE: If you
don't mind telling us,
what percentage of your
players pay to play?
KAJ NYGREN: Uh, no I can't
share that data, unfortunately.
AUDIENCE: Roughly.
KAJ NYGREN: I can't.
But we're actually, I
mean, we're like Ruzzle,
the game Ruzzle is actually
not a proper free to play game.
It's a freemium type of game.
So you have your free
experience with ads,
then they can buy premium.
And we have a pretty
good conversion rate
usually of people
actually paying
for premium, that I can say.
The fall of Ruzzle
Adventure, which
is in prelaunch, that's more
of a proper free to play game.
RICHARD HYNDMAN: OK,
thank you very, Kaj.
[APPLAUSE]